[Music]
here we go y'all this is a woman's quote
non-negotiable all right for having a
baby which in it's a list of her
non-negotiables which includes
$250,000 doll basically in yearly salary
and or allowance okay I'm going to go
over this list and I want you to
objectively or subjectively I should say
I guess it depends on who she's marrying
cuz like if it's a if she's marrying
like a billionaire then it's like it's
like a prenup let's not worry about that
let's you got a picture of her I do cuz
the finer you are the more you can
demand what if Nick trainer at
Jiu-Jitsu does that change the argument
yeah have you guys seen it's all
subjective it's all subjective it
depends on what your preference is
beautiful she could ask she could ask
for some money dude let me throw out a
couple disclaimers first I feel like
skin though man model okay you know what
it reminds me of it reminds me of like
someone like like that's modeling and
then they're like all right to afford me
to make me quit what I'm doing right now
you got to match my salary you got to do
this you got to do that whatever yeah
that's why to me it's like what do you
bring to the table and then you can make
demands based off that okay so I'm a
couple disclaimers again number one we
do not speak on behalf of all men so
don't okay does number two she doesn't
want to have children so these are her
non-negotiables if she has to have a
child for somebody who like wants to
that's her
choice that's her choice yeah whatever
she wants if you don't want to have
children why do you want to have
children she does want
to um and on compute she's saying
change my mind right yeah she's saying
she got the coffee mug she's say change
my mind he her thoughts yeah cuz she
believes that having children is going
to do like internal external damage to
her so it's like to make it worth it
this is my condition your body it
changes your Anatomy yeah for sure yeah
totally okay everything so he's a Steven
Crowder but like a black model version
okay so number one on the list is a
prenup before the pregnancy that covers
all bases and maners of things like
cheating Etc that's tight
okay usually a if a gold digger was
coming to the you know agreement they
don't want the that's why I think it's
typ so like how come she I think this is
more of like uh especially on the
concept of it's like if he cheats then
XYZ maybe or something like that like
for example he's got to take care of all
the child care like a prenup in her
favor I think it's tight that she's
going into it like that all right the
next on the list is a $250,000 allowance
annually per baby including weekly
therapy sessions personal trainer Etc
therapy damn annual annually okay
already that's every
year to the baby 18 okay that's what the
200 wait it's 250,000 per baby until the
baby's 18 that's fair and that ain't
even hurt baby say that baby's
18 okay she says basically this will
cover my weekly therapy sessions I'm
going to need before and post giving
birth personal trainer to get me all fit
and healthy and get my confidence back
obviously grocery shopping and just
things I would need to get that's if she
gives birth to the baby though yeah yeah
yeah oh okay okay and if I just have an
annual or monthly all allowance
equivalent to that then I would be able
to live comfortably not just for myself
but for my child as well you know you
know what I really like how like
whenever these things come up and people
are listening to this and they go like
man that sounds terrible like you always
have a girl going just say you
broke yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to not
sound like I'm broke right now oh yeah
that's fair like that's like 5K to me
that right now what she just demand 5K
that's all I B yeah actual retail price
we have we have five we have five right
50,000 yeah okay my bad that's pretty
high nobody thinks that nobody thinks
it's that
much but I mean okay if you're like
let's say you're dating nothing but
billionaires and Millionaires and then
like I've heard that they commoditize
like they just negotiate they just
everything's a commodity like everything
is like okay if you want this and then
this is what's it might be a world that
I'm just not a part of cuz I still
believe in love like I still like leten
it sounds like most people that have
this overview of like this is how it's
going to be it sounds like they're
lightly from the sugar dating world
because that is how they communicate
they're very like hey I need this I need
that I need that I need this allowance
and then I'll be your you know mhm so it
seems like that's like they graduated up
until like oh if you want me all the
time like if you want me if you want to
buy me out it feels like it's no longer
the girlfriend experience contract a
wife experence a wife experience gff's
off the table cuz then otherwise who's
commun that way off the bat like you
kind of have to get to that she
definitely gets approached only by like
billionaires well that's what Joe wants
he doesn't want to be buttered up for an
hour you know he just wants to know what
you want do you love me or not up after
as well ah yeah tell me how great I am
after we sign the contract next on the
list is a baby moon I guess that's fair
baby moon what's that oh is it like when
you go on a honeymoon before the baby
comes oh or maybe and or maybe after I
don't know no no no I think I think it's
when you're pregnant when you're
pregnant go on last trip because you
know going to be locked down for the
first year got it oh yeah I think that's
a baby man you should stipulate have
your legal team take care of that term
cuz that that could be interpreted
weirdly uh and then next on the list is
will not be working so if she has a kid
she's just not working yeah I figured
that I figur that wait is she already
even married to make these demands to
her husband or is it just I think I
think she's just a social media
personality and then she's putting this
out in the in the universe that's cool
communication nice is uh a housekeeper
for 6 months post birth to take care of
laundry cooking cleaning Etc that's
that's actually reasonable so she's
assuming after 6 months I can take those
over now versus some people go said she
needs a housekeeper for 6 months some
people will demand a housekeeper for the
rest of their life I bet that change
replace after the 6 months it becomes a
year a weekly uh weekly there thereof
yeah that's pretty reasonable that's
that's our first reasonable offer or
Demand on top of a quar million a year
that's crazy on top of for sure she
ain't working I'm not broke though I'm
just saying that's crazy so what happens
what happens he can afford it he can AFF
it just say you broke
bar like
this what happens year three when it's
like hey babe I'm leid on the payment
for the
250 yeah what are we talking about like
what's the penalty what gets repossessed
yeah the baby honestly the baby is put
back in list that out like
well then you got to give me the
Rolls-Royce then hey Bab I'm so sorry
I'm I'm running L on this I
got to next just tell me you're
broke
busted she uh next wrote a mummy
makeover because my body is going to be
destroyed internally and externally
destroyed I thought this when you're the
most beautiful freaking women thank you
they can't make up their mind make up
your goddamn mind thank you are you
beautiful when you're pregnant or are
you ugly have a beauty
standard that's what nobody says a mommy
make over refers to cosmetic surgeries
that you might choose to have after
giving birth to alter the changes your
body under goes during pregnancy and
child birth I'm cool with it okay yeah
I'm cool with it we've already said ages
ago this could mean a tummy tuck vaginal
rejuvenation surgery lipos how do you
rejuvenate the vad
Rejuvenation I mean what do they do for
that some of that is technically for us
so we have a young hot wife thank you
Joe exactly so I'm like getting your
lips nice and tight like is that
really for her nah it's for me exactly
yeah getting her lips nice that's
the thing that's weird about it it's
like if you're that if you're that
concerned with having a young hot wife
after your a real wife gave birth to
your baby then someone like that would
just go get a different young hot wife
no go get a surrogate that's what
theups oh yeah surate surate that's the
movie you don't mess up your wife at all
oh yeah that's what you mess up the
surrogate and then you don't ever talk
to her and then you don't have then you
can negotiate down from 250,000 a year
to like 60,000 cus sounds really very
one of them did that and then she was
talking about how like oh I don't feel
like as connected or some like that
I don't know well D she didn't go
through the turmoil of birth I
don't feel as connected yeah she was
like you know I don't feel as kind of
just feels like some sh I also don't
feel as connected as someone else's dump
that they took to the toilet I
know well the dump doesn't hear your
voice after being being in your body for
a certain amount of time and then turn
their head hey that' be a sick ass but
just after the dump do skin to skin with
it which is what I heard which is what I
heard by the way got a friend who did
this via surrogate and like the
surrogate mom was around and every time
that voice was heard the baby turns the
head towards the serate shut up sure
dude yeah cuz like it's N9 months is
long time yeah and then it's hearing and
then it's being like the vibration
atmosphere see that's why I wouldn't do
a surate because you don't know what
kind of Voodoo is going
on in that bitch's heart it's just fake
stuff it's fake things what if she's
thinking about negative things all the
time and the baby's being
injected with all that bad habit horror
movies and wow I agree watching hor
next would be a Night Nurse to be hired
so that she could get enough sleep and
wake up able to look after the child in
the morning God damn just get a doula
bro you no you need a night NSE
D Doula or what's the other one what's
the other version of that
did you get one get no pair we didn't no
we didn't have one and I was trying to
be there to support Gio every time so
every time she would uh breastfeed I
would wake up too and suck on the other
titty and I'm just like God yeah I'm
like God Dam sick I'm like this is
tiring dude tough yeah and like
we woke up so I woke up with her every
single time childish Jesus what I say
don't say those things it's tiring
as man I'm like dude if we have
another one we need to get one of them
night nurses or whatever the they
are Night Nurse lastly it was a p P
present have you guys ever heard of this
I don't want to know this one I don't
want to know a push present so either an
apartment in her name a car or a
business because she wanted she
explained that she needs to secure her
and her child's future oh like a AKA
signing bonus like an asset here's an
Escalade on top of our Arrangement hey
here's a business go ahead but managing
a business takes work and she said she
didn't want to work not if she's so my
great aunt owns like as a shareholder
like majority of a business she didn't
have to do do it's like a ran by
executive but like if she gets an
apartment in her name but she also has a
housekeeper it's like she's good but if
she gets J Hawaii we know she's got to
work yeah cuz my buddy owns it and he
got to work the thing oh yeah
not David he's the brain no not D he's
the ideasideas yeah he's got like ideas
about advertising and St yeah you just
got to be the David yeah yeah good old
David damn that's the whole list huh
yeah I mean that's a list that was
printed out I don't know she's got like
X isn't this like a whole thing with
like strong independent women that are
coming out of like uh Miami and like
these New York and like that's kind of
like a whole I know what I want I know
my worth and then they have a whole
checklist that strong independent just
go with all the things that you need
yeah not work go get your go get
your worth then get your bag girl
someone's going to pay for it if
somebody's willing to pay for who gives
a there's nothing wrong with the
list that's why when when people see
that and they're just like yeah right
it's like I don't know man in the sugar
dating phenomena that that's like a
impacted industry like you can't there's
so many people on both sides how long
did we research it 3 minutes what that
that's what I'm saying what are you
talking about we're a credible news
source that only gives the truth that's
that's what I'm saying exactly what he's
saying it's like we don't know we
we judge we judge it based on like what
we read for like 4 minutes at a time we
don't know anything we give disclaimers
in the video beginning of our video so
everything is like cool and I bet
there's a sugar daddy out there that's
reading this and is like like oh finally
some clear terms dude that's that's what
I'm saying I'm not going to sit here and
say that I'm down for a sugar she wrote
it out thank you I'm not saying that I'm
sitting here that I'm okay with a sugar
mama sending me money even though I have
a wife and if she's cool with that
relationship we don't have to have sex
or anything like that and she just pays
for certain things or gives you money
annually I'm just saying that's cool I'm
down return for c Pi of you being like
yeah yeah I can do it I got my own list
too mine is like you better not know
what you want to eat every time we try
to get food so many you better talk back
to me I I'll bring up a good idea you
better on
it you better tell me you can't do it
yeah you better B just say you're broke
you better yeah B just say it
yeah just say it you better call me fat
home I'm in the best shape of my life
that's crazy is that basically by her
making this list she's trying to narrow
people down so the more people that are
going this is stupid it's
working she choosing the filter not for
you bud she's trying to find the one
dude that can go for this but I mean if
she doesn't get anyone then she still
wins cuz she never wanted kids in the
first place cuz she didn't need no body
anyway right but next year it's like
okay just
200,000